Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are breaking barriers with Daniel Gennardu, a professional footballer with a first class psychology degree. We are tackling the turf
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将与丹尼尔·吉纳杜（Daniel Gennardu）一起打破壁垒，他是一位拥有心理学一等学位的职业足球运动员。我们将深入探讨球场
and the mind as we look at the surprising similarities between a career in football and one in professional psychology. Whether you are in the world of psychology, you're a football fan or both, I think you'll find this a really useful listen. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. So I started my psychology journey with psychology A-levels and a psychology degree. But of course, our interest before, during and after our psychology studies can take us in very different directions. I love hearing about where people are taking or
与心理世界，看看足球生涯与职业心理学职业生涯之间令人惊讶的相似之处。无论你是身处心理学界、足球迷，还是两者兼顾，我想你都会觉得这是一次非常有益的聆听。嗨，欢迎来到《准心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我从心理学A-level课程和心理学学位开始了自己的心理学之旅。当然，我们在心理学学习之前、期间和之后的兴趣可能会把我们带向非常不同的方向。我喜欢听人们谈论他们正在或
planning on taking their psychology degrees and how they use their psychological underpinnings and theories to make sense of the world that they find themselves in. I'm so excited to introduce you to our guest today who is himself a podcast host but I have to confess I was a terrible podcast host in today's episode because I forgot to ask him for all his details about where you can connect and where you can listen to his podcast. So I said that I would share the social links before and after our chat. Daniel Gennardou can be found on YouTube, which is where his podcast is, and the podcast Beyond Football is also available on Spotify and Apple Podcasts. You can also follow Daniel on Instagram, on LinkedIn and TikTok,
计划如何利用他们的心理学学位，以及他们如何运用心理学基础和理论来理解他们所处的世界。我非常高兴向大家介绍今天的嘉宾，他本人也是一位播客主持人，但我必须承认，我在今天的节目中是一位糟糕的播客主持人，因为我忘了问他关于在哪里可以联系到他以及在哪里可以收听他的播客的详细信息。所以我说我会在我们的谈话前后分享社交链接。丹尼尔·吉纳杜可以在YouTube上找到，他的播客就在那里，播客《超越足球》（Beyond Football）也可以在Spotify和Apple Podcasts上收听。你也可以在Instagram、LinkedIn和TikTok上关注丹尼尔，
where he is Daniel Gennadu. In case you're listening rather than watching, I'll spell that for you. Daniel is D-A-N-I-E-L. Gennadu is J-I-N-A-D-U. So I can only apologise to Daniel. I was a little bit distracted with my little boy who had very sore skin and had been sent home from school. So I can only only apologize but I will
他的名字是Daniel Gennadu。如果你是在听而不是在看，我会为你拼写一下。Daniel是D-A-N-I-E-L。Gennadu是J-I-N-A-D-U。所以我只能向丹尼尔道歉。我当时有点分心，因为我的小儿子皮肤很痛，刚被学校送回家。所以我只能再次道歉，但我会
look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this episode where I will share those links with you again. I hope you find this really useful. I just want to welcome Daniel to the podcast today. Hi Daniel. Hello, hello Dr Marianne. Thank you very much for having me oh thank you for saying yes so we first connected on LinkedIn and I was really interested in chatting to you because not only are you a first class psychology graduate well done to you on that but you are a professional football player and you really really care about the welfare of players past and present and you're really mindful about what it does to a person to kind of come out the end of a system like football and I think that's really commendable no thank you very much I feel like it's it's all down to to obviously being a player and seeing
期待在这一集结束时与你再次联系，届时我会再次分享这些链接。希望你觉得这很有用。我只想欢迎丹尼尔来到今天的播客。嗨，丹尼尔。你好，你好，玛丽安博士。非常感谢你邀请我。哦，谢谢你答应参加。我们最初是在LinkedIn上建立联系的，我非常有兴趣和你聊天，因为你不仅是一位心理学一等学位毕业生——为你感到骄傲——而且你还是一位职业足球运动员，你非常非常关心过去和现在的球员的福利，并且你非常在意离开足球这样的体系对一个人意味着什么，我认为这非常值得称赞。不，非常感谢你。我觉得这完全归功于作为一名球员，并看到
the effects that not having an identity beyond football can have on your career and your your future life chances so that's why I'm so passionate about it yeah yeah it's really important and you know I think until voices are amplified it doesn't stop people it doesn't make people think it doesn't make people think about the person as well as the player and you know I know that there's certain parallels here between aspiring psychologists who want to get onto professional qualifications and obviously professional footballers, because there's only so many places at the elite level in both of these careers. And it's really, really hard. And sometimes it's just subtle nuances in it. It's like just, it's just not quite right, or it's just not quite the right time.
没有足球之外的身份会对你的职业生涯和未来生活机会产生的影响，这就是我为什么对此充满热情。是的，这真的很重要。你知道，我认为在声音被放大之前，它不会阻止人们，不会让人们思考，不会让人们在看待球员的同时也看待作为“人”的他们。而且我知道，准心理学家想要获得专业资格与职业足球运动员之间存在某些相似之处，因为在这两个职业中，精英级别的名额都是有限的。这真的非常非常困难。有时只是细微的差别。就像是，感觉不太对，或者时机不太对。
And there's not necessarily anything that's wrong with you as a person or a player. It's really, really tricky, isn't it? Yeah, it's very, it's very tricky. I feel like, yeah, there's a lot of similarities there. And it's the dark world that we live in, ultimately. There's a lot of similarities there and it's it's the dark world that we live in ultimately there's a lot of competition there's a lot of um survival of the fittest so you have to present yourself in the in the best way making sure that you're gaining gaining the edge between yourself and the other
作为一个人或一名球员，你本身并不一定有什么问题。这真的非常非常棘手，不是吗？是的，非常棘手。我觉得，是的，这里有很多相似之处。这是我们最终所处的黑暗世界。这里有很多相似之处，这是我们最终所处的黑暗世界。这里有很多竞争，有很多“适者生存”，所以你必须以最好的方式展示自己，确保你在自己和其他
other players or the other side aspiring sports psychologists or places because yeah even before I started studying psychology I was told of how competitive it is to get onto master's courses to get onto your stage two of your qualified training etc but for me as a footballer that competitive side of it it motivates me because I'm quite competitive so I like coming out on top and winning when the odds are stacked against me so I feel like it's just about the way you reframe it and use it as fuel. Absolutely and I think in both of the careers you are shoulder to shoulder with your competition but they're also your friends and your colleagues. And there's also so much to be gained by kind of building one another up as well as elbowing them out the way.
球员或准运动心理学家之间获得优势。因为是的，甚至在我开始学习心理学之前，我就被告知进入硕士课程、进入资格培训的第二阶段等是多么具有竞争力。但对我来说，作为一名足球运动员，这种竞争的一面激励了我，因为我很有竞争力，所以我喜欢在胜算不大的情况下脱颖而出并获胜。所以我感觉这只是关于你如何重新定义它并将其用作燃料。绝对是这样。而且我认为在这两个职业中，你都与竞争对手并肩作战，但他们同时也是你的朋友和同事。而且，通过相互扶持以及竞争，也有很多收获。
It's a really tricky playing field to navigate, isn't it? Yeah, I feel like you perfectly described the situation of a goalkeeper or the goalkeeper dynamic in terms of only one goalkeeper can play and get that spot, that spotlight. But oftentimes teams in the Premier League, they have two or three goalkeepers. So the goalkeepers who are not playing, they talk about the goalkeeper union.
这是一个非常棘手的竞争环境，不是吗？是的，我觉得你完美地描述了守门员的情况或守门员的动态，因为只有一个守门员可以上场并获得那个聚光灯。但通常英超球队有两到三个守门员。所以那些没有上场的守门员，他们谈论“守门员联盟”。
The goalkeeper union is quite a tight-knit culture and environment between goalkeepers because they know it is quite a tight-knit culture and environment between goalkeepers because they know it's quite a lonely position but goalkeepers are able to empathize with other goalkeepers about the demands of the game the mental side of the game how tough it is so we're able to be close friends with with our competitor our fellow goalkeeper but at the same time we want that spot so it's an interesting dynamic to have in terms of competition and healthy sportsmanship. It really is and I think there's some I'm a mummy of a goalkeeper as well he's much younger than you he's at much end much earlier stage of his
守门员联盟是守门员之间一种非常紧密的文化和环境，因为他们知道这是一个非常孤独的位置，但守门员能够与其他守门员产生共鸣，理解比赛的要求、比赛的心理层面以及它的艰难程度。所以我们能够与我们的竞争对手、我们的守门员同伴成为亲密的朋友，但同时我们又想要那个位置。所以这在竞争和健康的体育精神方面是一个有趣的动态。确实如此，而且我想，我也是一位守门员的妈妈，他比你年轻得多，他处于职业生涯的
career he's seven but even this morning on the walk to school he was talking about his game this weekend and he was saying there's only so much i can do mum because it's about the defense if if they're not helping me or if they don't listen to me when i say keepers ball like it's really hard and i'm i don't know what to say to him what what would you say to him yeah for me as a young goalkeeper, I struggled. I struggled. And he's asking the right questions. So he's very intelligent because ultimately there's not much you can do.
早期阶段，他才七岁。但即使是今天早上走在上学的路上，他还在谈论他这个周末的比赛。他说：“妈妈，我能做的只有这么多，因为这取决于防守。如果他们不帮我，或者当我说‘守门员球’时他们不听我的，这真的很难。”我不知道该对他说什么。你会对他说什么？是的，作为一名年轻的守门员，我曾经挣扎过。我挣扎过。他在问正确的问题。所以他非常聪明，因为归根结底，你无能为力。
You can only control what you can control. But as a young goalkeeper, I never understood that because ultimately all young goalkeepers, we all want to keep a clean sheet we want to save everything we want to do our job for the team but ultimately that's not always always possible so that obviously had a big impact on me in terms of my ability to deal with those those situations and influenced me even going and studying psychology and going down that pathway and etc yeah yeah and I know
你只能控制你能控制的事情。但作为一名年轻的守门员，我从未理解这一点，因为归根结底，所有年轻的守门员，我们都想保持零封，我们想扑出每一个球，我们想为球队做好我们的工作，但归根结底，这并不总是可能的。所以这显然对我处理这些情况的能力产生了很大影响，甚至影响了我去学习心理学并走上那条道路等等。是的，是的，我知道
that when we first connected on LinkedIn you were without a team at that point and so really really tricky stuff how how did you navigate all of that how did you keep your focus up how did you go about finding a team and kind of keeping your fitness up to such a level that you could kind of drop back into a team it must have been really challenging yes it's a challenging experience for for anyone in terms of um release handling release and deselection and ultimately yeah how did I keep the faith? Ultimately, number one thing is I'm a believer, I'm a Christian, so I have a firm foundation in terms of my Christian belief and having hope.
当我们第一次在LinkedIn上联系时，你当时没有球队，所以这真的很棘手。你是如何应对这一切的？你是如何保持专注的？你是如何找到球队并保持体能水平，以至于可以重新加入球队的？这一定非常具有挑战性。是的，对于任何人来说，处理解约和被淘汰都是一种具有挑战性的经历。归根结底，我是如何保持信念的？首先，我是一个信徒，我是一名基督徒，所以我在基督教信仰方面有坚实的基础，并且拥有希望。
We talk about faith being the substance of things hoped for, the evidence of things not seen. So that really helped me stay grounded and motivated to not take rejection as the final final message but as well I have a good a good support network around me good family that have helped me to to see who I truly am and what I can become so that helped me keep on pushing on even when times get tough and you're just thinking what's going to happen a lot lot of uncertainty, a lot of doubt. But also as well, I think that motivated me as well,
我们谈论信仰是所望之事的实底，是未见之事的确据。所以这真的帮助我保持脚踏实地，并有动力不把拒绝视为最终的结论。但同时，我身边也有一个很好的支持网络，很好的家人，他们帮助我看到我真正是谁以及我可以成为什么样的人。所以这帮助我即使在困难时期也能继续前进，即使你只是在想会发生什么，有很多不确定性，有很多怀疑。但同时，我认为这也激励了我，
was that genuine belief from deep inside me that I have what it takes to play at the highest level because I put in the work and I feel like I have the skill and the talent. So those are the few different things that helped me through those periods. Yeah, really important stuff. And actually, again, as a parallel to psychology, you know, it's that persistence. It's that perseverance, isn't it? So you could at that point have hung your boots up and been like, this isn't for me anymore. But there's one sure thing that stops your career trajectory or stops you developing in the way that you wanted and that that is saying I'm not doing
那就是我内心深处真正的信念，我相信我有能力在最高水平上比赛，因为我付出了努力，我觉得我有技能和天赋。所以这些是帮助我度过那些时期的几件不同的事情。是的，非常重要的事情。实际上，作为心理学的平行线，你知道，这就是坚持。这就是毅力，不是吗？所以你当时本可以挂靴，觉得“这不再适合我了”。但有一件事肯定会停止你的职业轨迹或阻止你以想要的方式发展，那就是说“我不做了”。
it anymore and you know the same with psychology you know doctorate courses can be so tricky to get on that people like I'm not doing this anymore and so of course if you don't go for a second or a third or a fourth attempt that is going to be the end of your professional psychology career certainly at that point um so that is again an evidence of perseverance you know creating the results because if you had tried a fourth or a fifth time that might have led to results but it is really tricky to to not burn out and it's really interesting to hear about your faith and of course your family being so important to you in that regard um how do you keep friendships because I'm sure they're such a key part of of you but what we know about kind of friendships is that they can be friends for a reason friends for a season and friends for lifetime and the guys
你知道，心理学也是一样，博士课程可能很难进入，以至于人们会说“我不做了”。所以当然，如果你不进行第二次、第三次或第四次尝试，那将是你职业心理学生涯的终点，至少在那个时候是这样。所以这再次证明了毅力，你知道，创造结果，因为如果你尝试了第四次或第五次，那可能会带来结果。但要不精疲力竭真的很难，听到你的信仰以及你的家人在这方面对你如此重要，真的很有趣。你是如何保持友谊的？因为我相信他们是你如此关键的一部分，但我们所知道的关于友谊的是，它们可以是“有原因的朋友”、“有季节的朋友”和“一辈子的朋友”。和你一起踢球的那些人，
that you're playing with and probably even you know everybody in the team can feel like such a key part of you but when you leave the team does that translate into real life and are you able to keep some people to kind of take you forward and to support you in the next stages of your career yeah definitely before i answer that question i wanted to just build on what you said about um persistence needed obviously psych sports sacks and how it's parallel to footballers and their persistence i feel like it's it's so importants and how it's parallel to footballers and their persistence. I feel like it's so important. I feel like it's the difference
甚至可能球队里的每个人都感觉是你如此关键的一部分，但当你离开球队时，这会转化为现实生活吗？你能够留住一些人来带你前进并在你职业生涯的下一阶段支持你吗？是的，当然。在我回答这个问题之前，我想先补充一下你所说的关于心理学和运动心理学所需的坚持，以及它如何与足球运动员及其坚持平行。我觉得这非常重要。我觉得这是
between being successful and not being successful. Your ability to handle your bounce back ability. They talk about failing big and multiple times before you can get it right and it clicks.
成功与不成功之间的区别。你处理反弹的能力。他们谈论在成功之前要经历多次巨大的失败，然后才会豁然开朗。
So if you don't have the grit or the resilience to, to film multiple times and be rejected multiple, multiple times, then I don't feel like you have what it takes to be successful. It's a, I feel like it's an, it's an important skill to have. And then your question about um friendships and the football
所以如果你没有毅力或韧性去经历多次失败并被多次拒绝，那么我不觉得你有能力成功。我觉得这是一种重要的技能。然后关于你的问题，关于友谊和足球
system yeah I feel like it's depending on it's similar to a workplace a workplace environment where you get on with some of your colleagues some better better than others so that's how it's been at different clubs that I've been at there There's been people I've created close bonds with that the friendship lasts, you know, beyond you playing for that club or beyond the different environments that you're in. But there's other friendships that might not have gone to that deeper level.
体系，是的，我觉得这取决于它，它类似于工作场所，工作环境，你与一些同事相处得很好，比其他人更好。所以我在我待过的不同俱乐部就是这样。有些人我建立了亲密的纽带，这种友谊持续到你不再为那个俱乐部效力或超越你所处的不同环境之后。但也有其他友谊可能没有达到那种更深的层面。
But I feel like it's so important because, you know, football, they say football especially, it's a small world, you know, football, they say football especially is a small world, you know. Everyone knows everyone to an extent. So, you know, having those close connections and being able to relate when you go to another club to say something, oh, you know Will. And then you're able to have similar,
但我感觉这非常重要，因为，你知道，足球，他们说足球尤其是一个小世界，你知道。每个人在某种程度上都认识每个人。所以，你知道，拥有那些紧密的联系，并且当你去另一个俱乐部时能够产生共鸣，说“哦，你认识威尔”。然后你就能够有类似的，
that's that initial bonding connection that you're able to have with other people. So you're able to build rapport with other people at other places that you're able to have with other people so you're able to build rapport with other other people at other places that you go to great thank you and thank you for for bringing me back to the one that i just kind of moved on from it's really really important to kind of let you have your say as well so thank you for doing that with me um yeah like i watched ted lasso have you watched ted lasso i've seen i've seen this trailer i haven't actually watched so good it's so good so i would never have thought it would be my cup of tea um and i ended up i bought a an apple watch a while ago and they gave me three months free apple tv so that's what gave me that but i watched
那种最初的联系，你能够与其他人建立联系。所以你能够在其他地方与其他人建立融洽的关系。太棒了，谢谢你。谢谢你把我带回我刚刚跳过的话题。让你也有发言权真的非常非常重要，所以谢谢你和我一起这样做。嗯，是的，我看过《泰德·拉索》（Ted Lasso），你看过《泰德·拉索》吗？我看过预告片，但我还没真正看过。太棒了，真的太棒了。所以我从来没想过它会是我的菜。我前段时间买了一块Apple Watch，他们给了我三个月免费的Apple TV，所以这就是我观看的原因。但我看了
it and it's honestly one of the best shows I've ever watched there was a slightly dodgy patch in series two which was a bit weird um but series one two and three I just loved them like such great characters and if anyone's like what is Ted Lasso it is um the story of a premiership manager and the team and the people that are kind of within that and it's it's great so i would recommend i mean for you it might not feel like like do i watch shows about psychology yes i probably would but um you know is there an interest in that are you like also footballed out that you're like no that's gonna wait for another day in terms of watching yeah and you know watching the the netflix beckham you know documentary i watch it i watch it there's there's so many out there's so many out that it's
它，它真的是我看过的最好的节目之一。第二季有一个稍微有点奇怪的阶段，有点怪。但第一、二、三季我都非常喜欢，角色太棒了。如果有人问什么是《泰德·拉索》，它是关于一位英超经理和球队以及其中的人们的故事，它很棒。所以我推荐它。我的意思是，对你来说，这可能感觉不像……我会看关于心理学的节目吗？是的，我可能会看。但，你知道，有兴趣吗？你是不是也看腻了足球，觉得“不，那改天再说”？是的，你知道，看Netflix的贝克汉姆纪录片，我看了，我看了。外面有太多太多了，
difficult to keep up that's the thing so i've watched i've watched the david beckham documentary i watched the all of the all or nothings on Amazon Prime. Is that the Man City one? My kids are watching the Man City one at the moment. There's a Man City one. There's an Arsenal one. And there's
很难跟上，这就是问题所在。所以我看了大卫·贝克汉姆的纪录片，我看了亚马逊Prime上的所有《孤注一掷》（All or Nothing）。那是曼城的那部吗？我的孩子们现在正在看曼城的那部。有一部曼城的。有一部阿森纳的。还有
another one. My kids have been rooting for a Spurs one. They are Spurs fans and my husband. Dirty words. I for a Spurs one. They are Spurs fans and my husband. I don't know. Dirty words. I don't think that will come about. The stadium was amazing, though.
另一部。我的孩子们一直支持热刺的那部。他们是热刺球迷，还有我丈夫。脏话。我支持热刺的那部。他们是热刺球迷，还有我丈夫。我不知道。脏话。我不认为那会实现。不过球场太棒了。
I did visit there in the summer for my eldest boy's birthday. And the Spurs stadium is just incredible. Like, really, really amazing place. So tell me about the team that you play for at the moment. You're coming to the end of the season and you're just telling me that you just won at the weekend. So congratulations to you and the team on that win. Thank you very much.
我夏天为了我大儿子的生日去过那里。热刺球场简直不可思议。真的，非常非常棒的地方。那么告诉我关于你目前效力的球队。你快要结束这个赛季了，你刚才告诉我你周末刚赢了比赛。所以祝贺你和球队取得胜利。非常感谢。
Yeah, what would you like to know about the team? What's it like? What's it like being part of the team? What's it, you know, are they welcoming and supportive? I guess, what's it like when you're having to answer to the fans? You know, especially as a goalkeeper,
是的，你想了解球队的什么？感觉如何？成为球队的一员感觉如何？它，你知道，他们热情好客且支持吗？我想，当你不得不回应球迷时感觉如何？你知道，尤其是作为一名守门员，
it must be very difficult. People can be really mouthy, can't they? And, you know, probably even within your team and probably getting jibed by the other players, like, how do you manage all of that? Yeah, it's through experience, through developing different coping mechanisms over the years.
这一定非常困难。人们真的可以很刻薄，不是吗？而且，你知道，可能甚至在你的球队内部，也可能被其他球员嘲笑，你是如何处理这一切的？是的，是通过经验，通过多年来发展出不同的应对机制。
But, yeah, the team are amazing. I feel like we've got a good dynamic of people in and around the changing room. We've got a good dynamic of people in and around the changing room. We've got great banter. So we enjoy our work. Training is not – there's never a dull day. There's never a dull day out on the pitch or in the changing room or when we go out together.
但是，是的，球队太棒了。我觉得我们在更衣室里和周围有一群很好的动态的人。我们在更衣室里和周围有一群很好的动态的人。我们有很好的玩笑。所以我们享受我们的工作。训练不是——从来没有沉闷的一天。在球场上或更衣室里，或者当我们一起出去时，从来没有沉闷的一天。
So it's really good. The fans, yeah. The Maidenhead fans are amazing in terms of the support and everything but opposition fans can be, can be a pin in the arse. Especially as a goalkeeper,
所以这真的很好。球迷们，是的。梅登黑德（Maidenhead）的球迷在支持和一切方面都很棒，但客队球迷可能会，可能会是个讨厌鬼。尤其是作为一名守门员，
we get all the stick saying, you know, we get abuse not only to us, to our family members sometimes, to different things,
我们受到所有的指责，你知道，我们不仅受到辱骂，有时还会波及我们的家庭成员，以及不同的事情，
yeah, but it's part of the game, it's part of the job. You almost have to harden yourself to that a little bit and just Yeah, it's part of the game. It's part of the job. You almost have to harden yourself to that a little bit and just expect that it's not. People aren't always going to like you and that's just how it is
是的，但这是比赛的一部分，这是工作的一部分。你几乎必须让自己对此稍微硬化一点，只是……是的，这是比赛的一部分。这是工作的一部分。你几乎必须让自己对此稍微硬化一点，只是预料到它不会。人们并不总是会喜欢你，事实就是这样，
and it's not personal. It's just, it is what it is. Exactly that. Exactly that. Yeah. And has racism, I know racism is trying to stamp it out in football,
而且这不是针对个人的。它只是，事实就是这样。完全正确。完全正确。是的。而且种族主义，我知道足球界正在努力消除种族主义，
but I'm sure that's not universal. Has that cropped up for you? Yeah, no, thankfully I haven't actually experienced direct racism in terms of when I've been playing or anything, but there is different forms in terms of indirectly and the way players have been treated and everything. But thankfully I haven't had direct experiences with that good I'm pleased to hear that I think there's something around
但我敢肯定那不是普遍的。这在你身上出现过吗？是的，不，谢天谢地，我实际上并没有在踢球时经历过直接的种族主义。但确实有不同形式的间接种族主义，以及球员被对待的方式等等。但谢天谢地，我没有直接的经历。很好，我很高兴听到这个。我认为有一些关于
the younger generations generally being more inclusive more aware more thoughtful more mindful um my boys um well we're in Coventry which is a really kind of multicultural um city um and they're just watching their friendships with people of all races and all backgrounds is really really lovely and I've got um a nephew who's very similar in age to you and just the way that he talks um he's half Italian himself but the way he talks about his friends and their race and their background, and the way that they just would not stand for any discrimination, you know, in their friends, and that they would speak up to that, I think and hope that is the change in the younger generations, that people genuinely are like, you know know you're no different to me we may
年轻一代通常更具包容性、更清醒、更体贴、更用心。我的孩子们……嗯，我们在考文垂，这是一个非常多元文化的城市，他们只是看着他们与各种种族和背景的人的友谊，真的非常非常可爱。我有一个侄子，年龄和你差不多，他谈话的方式……他自己有一半意大利血统，但他谈论他的朋友以及他们的种族和背景的方式，以及他们绝不会容忍任何歧视的方式，你知道，在他们的朋友中，如果有人那样做，他们会站出来说话。我认为并希望这就是年轻一代的变化，人们真的会觉得，你知道，你和我没什么不同。我们可能
have different skin color we may have different faith but actually you know these are my friends and they're still really important to me I'm not going to let you say that to him or to them um that for me as a woman who's 42 um that feels like that's been a cultural shift hopefully in the UK which is gonna go from strength to strength I mean I can't change your age I can't show you what it was like for me when I was growing up and what it was like for my friends growing up but yeah I don't have you seen that change happen at all from your perspective over the last few years uh yeah yeah definitely I feel like um people are becoming wiser in terms of their understanding of people and how to treat people and interact with people who are not like you. For me, I can never wrap
有不同的肤色，我们可能有不同的信仰，但实际上，你知道，这些是我的朋友，他们对我来说仍然非常重要。我不会让你那样对他说或对他们说。对我来说，作为一个42岁的女性，这感觉像是英国发生的一种文化转变，希望它会越来越强。我的意思是，我无法改变你的年龄，我无法向你展示我成长时是什么样子，以及我的朋友成长时是什么样子。但，是的，从你的角度来看，过去几年你看到这种变化了吗？呃，是的，是的，绝对。我觉得人们在理解他人以及如何对待和与不像你的人互动方面变得更聪明了。对我来说，我永远无法理解
my head around racism or discriminating against someone because they're different or they look different to you. It just doesn't make sense. I think it's a level of stupidity, in my opinion. But yeah, I feel like there's definitely been a change or a positive step. Good, good. Long may it continue to thrive and develop. Thinking about you and psychology then, and you and psychology and goalkeeping you know we're
种族主义或因为某人与众不同或看起来与你不同而歧视某人。这根本说不通。在我看来，这是一种愚蠢。但是的，我觉得肯定有一个变化或积极的一步。很好，很好。愿它继续蓬勃发展。那么考虑到你和心理学，你和心理学以及守门员，你知道我们
thinking about the negative attribution bias which you might well recall you know you can have 10 experiences that are positive and and one that's not good and it will be the one that's not good that gets spoken about how do you manage that in terms of goalie because this is you saving 10 exceptional goals and letting one in and what we know is that that is the one that's likely to get talked about yeah yeah before i even get into this question i'd love to even just discuss about how i even got into psychology and studied it etc yeah so i started, I started, well, I first heard about psychology when I studied it at GCSE in year nine. So I studied it in year nine for GCSE and what really hooked me was just learning about just the science of behaviour. How, just understanding why people behave the way they behave. And what really got me really hooked into psychology
正在考虑负面归因偏差，你可能很清楚，你知道，你可以有10次积极的经历，而只有一次是不好的，但会被谈论的将是那次不好的。作为守门员，你是如何管理这一点的？因为这是你扑出了10个精彩的球，却漏掉了一个，而我们知道这很可能是会被谈论的那一个。是的，是的，在我回答这个问题之前，我很想讨论一下我是如何接触心理学并学习它的等等。是的，我开始，我开始，嗯，我第一次听说心理学是在九年级学习GCSE时。所以我九年级时学习了GCSE心理学，真正吸引我的是学习行为科学。如何，只是理解为什么人们会有那样的行为。真正让我迷上心理学的是
was learning about Ash's study and conformity, the psychological phenomenon in which people change their beliefs or their behaviours because of the people around them. Learning about that and its influence on different aspects of literally everything made me just have that passion for it and made me continue studying it alongside my football, whilst I was playing for Chelsea and West Ham. So doing my A-level in psychology and then obviously going on to study at university.
学习阿什（Asch）的从众研究，这是一种心理现象，人们因为周围的人而改变自己的信仰或行为。学习这一点及其对几乎所有方面的影响，让我对它产生了热情，并使我在踢球的同时继续学习它，当时我还在为切尔西和西汉姆联效力。所以我在学习心理学A-level，然后显然去大学学习。
But negative attribution theories um as a goalkeeper when you how would you define attribute like attribution is talking about like the causes or what you basically describe the causes of something basically right yeah so it's it's what you see as a negative thing so it's a it's a negative judgment or negative label that you're applying to something and it's just you know it's that that one thing that that looks different or has gone wrong that's more likely to get remembered so it's like the novel concept so actually you know evolutionary it pays more sense to pay attention to the stuff that makes you sick or the stuff that actually feels really scary so that's why it exists as a concept so that it's not making
但负面归因理论……作为一名守门员，当你……你会如何定义归因？归因是在谈论原因，或者你基本上描述某事的原因，对吧？是的，所以这是你视为负面的东西，所以这是一个负面判断或负面标签，你正在将其应用于某事。而且它只是，你知道，那一件看起来不同或出错的事情，更容易被记住。所以它就像新奇的概念。所以实际上，你知道，从进化角度来看，关注那些让你生病或实际上感觉非常可怕的东西更有意义。所以这就是它作为一个概念存在的原因，这样它就不会让你
you miss anything that might be really really important for you um you know surviving whereas obviously things that feel good are good you know they release dopamine and all that jazz like who doesn't like a bit of dopamine but actually the thing things that feel awful or um you know are going to be releasing all of your stress hormones you know your cortisol and you know your all your nasty hormones that get your fight and flight going those are the things that are more likely to be dangerous to you and so it would make sense that we'd pay more attention to the negative things but obviously we're trying to navigate life with quite quite old brains in a modern world and it's it's a very different environment that we find
错过任何可能对你非常非常重要的事情，你知道，生存。而显然感觉良好的事情是好的，你知道，它们释放多巴胺和所有那些东西，谁不喜欢一点多巴胺呢？但实际上，感觉糟糕的事情，或者你知道，会释放你所有的压力荷尔蒙，你知道，你的皮质醇，你知道，所有那些让你进入战斗或逃跑状态的讨厌荷尔蒙，这些是更有可能对你危险的事情。所以我们更关注负面事情是有道理的。但显然我们正试图用相当古老的大脑在现代世界中导航生活，我们所处的环境与它们被设计时
ourselves in now than what they were designed for yeah definitely i feel like with that it's all about reframing it reframing the different situations or um aspects that you're in because what you're describing there is similar to obviously negative reinforcement we have a negative experience that reinforces behavior or even a bit of like paranoia in terms of okay cool you don't want that negative experience so then you might change your behaviour as a goalkeeper yeah we go through that a lot in terms of avoidance avoidance of negative experiences and avoidance of that fight or flight situation. We have to learn from a young age not to fight or flight because our job is to literally stand in front of a ball
的环境非常不同。是的，绝对。我觉得有了这个，一切都是关于重新定义它，重新定义你所处的不同情况或方面。因为你在这里描述的类似于负面强化，我们有负面经历，强化了行为，甚至有点像偏执，关于“好吧，酷，你不想要那种负面经历”，所以你可能会改变你的行为。作为一名守门员，是的，我们在避免负面经历和避免那种战斗或逃跑情况方面经历了很多。我们必须从小学会不要战斗或逃跑，因为我们的工作是字面上站在一个
that's moving at high speeds or maybe put our hand in front of a ball that might break one of our fingers. So it's not a natural human action so basically yeah we basically have to train our bodies to override those natural responses absolutely that is and it's not an easy thing to do you know even as I watch my boys and their teams play football you know sometimes they'll flinch or they'll turn their back on the ball. And you're having to really train yourself not to do that.
高速移动的球前面，或者可能把我们的手放在一个可能会折断我们手指的球前面。所以这不是一种自然的人类行为，所以基本上，是的，我们基本上必须训练我们的身体来覆盖那些自然的反应。绝对是这样，而且这不是一件容易做到的事情。你知道，即使我看着我的孩子们和他们的球队踢足球，你知道，有时他们会退缩，或者他们会背对球。而你必须真正训练自己不要那样做。
And I am scared of footballs, I have to say, from growing up in a comprehensive school where the football would fly over the net and hit you in the face and it's gritty and it's cold and it hurts. And it's also a bit humiliating. Like that's stayed with me as a bit of a trauma. And the kids know there's one thing that's going to annoy me it's hitting mummy in the face with a football um like it's really difficult and yeah like you you see goalies take balls to the face and all sorts and they've just gotta they've just gotta keep on haven't they you've just gotta you know keep your eye on what's
而且我害怕足球，我必须说，因为我在一所综合学校长大，足球会飞过球网打在你的脸上，它很粗糙，很冷，而且很痛。而且它也有点丢人。这就像一种创伤一样留在了我心里。孩子们知道有一件事会惹恼我，那就是用足球打妈妈的脸。嗯，这真的很难。而且，是的，就像你看到守门员被球打中脸和各种各样的情况，他们只是必须，他们只是必须坚持下去，不是吗？你只是必须，你知道，盯着正在
going on and kind of suppress your physical sensations and your emotions as well. It's not an easy job to do at all. No, not at all, not at all. Because one particular situation for me whilst coming through the academy system at Chelsea was learning the specific goalkeeping technique of a block save. A block save is a save where the striker or the person in opposition is quite close to the goal
发生的事情，并抑制你的身体感觉和你的情绪。这根本不是一份容易的工作。不，一点也不，一点也不。因为我在切尔西青训体系中成长时，有一个特定的情况是学习“封堵扑救”的特定守门员技术。封堵扑救是一种扑救，当对方的前锋或球员离球门很近时，
and you have to put your body frame in a lower position and make your body big as if you're blocking the ball from going past you, whether it hits your face or any part of your body, that ultimately is to prevent the ball from going past you. And a key tendency that a lot of younger goalkeepers have whenever they're learning that technique is to turn their face away because it's your natural response.
你必须把你的身体框架放在一个较低的位置，让你的身体变大，就好像你在阻挡球从你身边经过一样，无论它是打在你的脸上还是你身体的任何部位，这最终是为了防止球从你身边经过。而许多年轻守门员在学习该技术时的一个关键倾向是把脸转开，因为这是你的自然反应。
Because obviously you know that the ball is going to hit you, it's going to injure you, so your body is naturally going to turn your face away out of protection. So it was difficult for me to get out of that natural inclination to turn your head. But once you're making a block save, it's so important to make sure your head stays square, eyes on the ball, which is obviously contradictory to your natural responses but yeah just having that I thought that's what different skills that separates them high level goalkeepers from ones that are not as high level it's that fearlessness and it's another parallel there with psychology profession isn't it you've got to keep your eye on the game.
因为显然你知道球会打中你，它会伤害你，所以你的身体自然会为了保护而把脸转开。所以对我来说，摆脱那种转头的自然倾向是很困难的。但一旦你进行封堵扑救，确保你的头保持方正、眼睛盯着球是非常重要的，这显然与你的自然反应相矛盾。但是的，只是拥有那个……我认为这就是区分高水平守门员和水平没那么高的守门员的不同技能，那就是无畏。而且这与心理学职业有另一个相似之处，不是吗？你必须盯着比赛。
You've got to keep looking forward no matter what's trying to distract you or no matter what feels scary. Yeah, just really, really hard stuff that you're having to put your body and your mind through, Daniel. How old were you when you first got scouted? Yeah, I got scouted when I was 12. When was 12 I was playing for my for my local Sunday League team and we were doing we were doing quite well we were doing quite well um playing games and I remember the game so vividly it was one of the games where I think I had made an assist from my
无论有什么试图分散你的注意力，或者无论什么感觉可怕，你都必须继续向前看。是的，你必须让你的身体和思想经历的真的非常非常困难的事情，丹尼尔。你第一次被球探发现时多大？是的，我12岁时被球探发现。12岁时，我正在为我当地的周日联赛球队效力，我们做得相当不错，我们做得相当不错，嗯，踢比赛。我记得那场比赛非常生动，那是其中一场比赛，我想我从我的
goal so I literally just booted the ball up up the pitch and then the striker scored and I think I had made an assist from my goal. So I literally just booted the ball up the pitch and then the striker scored. And I think we ended up winning the game. And then after the game, went home, showering. Then my brother just knocks on the door and he's just screaming. He just said, wow, you got scouted by Chelsea. You got scouted by Chelsea.
球门助攻了一次，所以我字面上只是把球踢向球场，然后前锋得分了，我想我从我的球门助攻了一次。所以我字面上只是把球踢向球场，然后前锋得分了。我想我们最终赢得了比赛。比赛结束后，回家，洗澡。然后我哥哥敲门，他只是在尖叫。他只是说：“哇，你被切尔西球探发现了。你被切尔西球探发现了。”
And I was like, I didn't believe him at first. And then my mum came in to confirm it and we just we just started screaming and shouting and everything this was yeah amazing it's so lovely to watch you reflect on that because it's obviously still a really really fond memory you know you smiled as you were talking about it and even though you were 12 you know it's it's a key formative experience for you and one that has led to you being, you know, where you are now. Yeah, like really special stuff. But basically your whole adolescence and beyond has been kind of on the professional football scene.
我起初不相信他。然后我妈妈进来确认了，我们只是开始尖叫和欢呼，一切……这真是太棒了。看着你回顾这一点真是太可爱了，因为它显然仍然是一个非常非常美好的回忆。你知道，你在谈论它时微笑着，即使你当时12岁，你知道，这对你来说是一个关键的形成性经历，一个导致你成为现在这样的人的经历。是的，真的很特别。但基本上你的整个青春期及以后都在职业足球界。
Yeah, definitely. Did you live at home during the whole time or have you been kind of had the David Beckham effect of kind of moving away and having kind of house parents and all of that jazz? Yeah, I've had I've had a mixture of both. I've had a mixture of both. So I'm living at home through the early years and we often did trips away. So times away from home where we're staying with maybe host families staying at a hotel or going abroad I know when I was at Chelsea we went to five or six different countries on international tournaments and yeah moving abroad for when I played for Barnsley's living living on my own for the first time
是的，绝对。你整个期间都住在家里，还是你经历了像大卫·贝克汉姆那样的搬走并有寄宿家庭等等那种经历？是的，我两者都有。我两者都有。所以我在早年住在家里，我们经常去旅行。所以离开家的时间，我们可能和寄宿家庭住在一起，住在酒店，或者去国外。我知道我在切尔西时，我们去了五个或六个不同的国家参加国际锦标赛。是的，当我为巴恩斯利（Barnsley）效力时搬到国外，第一次独自生活
etc and staying at home all of that yeah again another psychology parallel as well so whilst we don't tend to move around internationally um for aspiring psychologist roles sometimes you can be flitting about all over the country for different roles and kind of starting again and trying to make new colleague relationships and kind of where you're going to live. And like, sometimes you might not even know where somewhere is and a job comes up and you think, oh, I'll give that a go. And, you know, then your whole life is different. And yes, it's kind of in your control
等等，住在家里，所有这些。是的，又是另一个心理学平行线。所以虽然我们倾向于不为了准心理学家职位而在国际上搬来搬去，但有时你可能会为了不同的职位在全国各地飞来飞去，重新开始，试图建立新的同事关系，以及你将住在哪里。而且，有时你甚至可能不知道某个地方在哪里，一个工作机会出现了，你心想，“哦，我会试一试。”而且，你知道，然后你的整个生活就不同了。而且是的，它在某种程度上是在你的控制之下。
because you could say no. But if you want your career to keep moving forward, it's not really a choice that you can say no to when that offer comes up. Yeah, definitely. Definitely. a choice that you can say no to when the when that offer comes up yeah definitely definitely it's just about being open to the different experiences and enjoying the journey yeah and you know I know there's probably is it the majority of professional footballers now are coming up through the academy systems but are there other ways to become professional footballers or you know what's that like at the moment yeah there is there is definitely other ways it's not only the academy
因为你可以说不。但如果你想让你的职业生涯继续前进，当那个机会出现时，你真的没法拒绝。是的，绝对是。绝对是。当那个机会出现时，你真的没法拒绝，是的，绝对是，绝对是。这只是关于对不同的经历保持开放态度并享受这段旅程。我知道现在大多数职业足球运动员都是通过青训系统成长起来的，但还有其他成为职业足球运动员的方法吗？或者说目前的情况是怎样的？是的，确实有其他方法，不仅仅是青训系统。
system route that is the only way it's even a main message that I was speaking with on one of my podcast episodes in terms of which is titled in a different way a different journey to becoming a professional football which is through through the non-league route and through them playing Sunday league and going up through the ranks of playing men's football from a young age I know a lot of a lot of clubs are valuing young players who have men's football experience from a young age because it's something that academy players might not have. Right. Okay. It's important stuff. Have you done any coaching yourself yet?
青训系统并不是唯一的途径，这甚至是我在我的播客节目中谈到的一个主要信息，那一期的标题是“成为职业足球运动员的不同途径”，即通过非联赛途径，通过参加周日联赛，从年轻时就开始参加成人足球比赛。我知道很多俱乐部都很看重那些从小就有成人足球经验的年轻球员，因为这是青训球员可能不具备的。对，好的。这很重要。你自己做过教练了吗？
Or you've done your refereeing? Or are you still firmly in player mode? Yeah, so I have my coaching badges. I have my UFSC FA Level 2. I've done the National Goalkeeping course last year. So I have a little bit of experience doing that. Amazing, amazing. And I'm sure once you've got that insight as well,
或者你做过裁判？还是说你仍然完全处于球员模式？是的，我有教练资格证。我有欧足联FA二级教练证书。去年我还参加了国家守门员课程。所以我在这方面有一点经验。太棒了，太棒了。我相信一旦你有了这种洞察力，
it makes you look differently on your own career and the people that have supported you as well. It gives you new insight when you learn new stuff, doesn't it? Definitely. So something that's cropped up for me in the last year as I broke my left arm in April last year and injury really sucks like it affects everything it affects the way you think about yourself like I'm quite into kind of sport and exercise and when you're injured you can't do that like you can't sleep it hurts you know I noticed my mood took a real dip is injury something that that's cropped up for you in your
它会让你以不同的眼光看待自己的职业生涯以及那些支持你的人。当你学到新东西时，它会给你新的见解，不是吗？绝对是。去年我左臂骨折了，受伤真的很糟糕，因为它影响了一切。它影响了你对自己的看法，比如我非常喜欢运动和锻炼，当你受伤时你就做不了这些，你睡不着，很痛。我注意到我的情绪真的很低落，受伤这件事在你的职业生涯中出现过吗？
career yeah it has it has it has my remember my first big injury was when I tore my tore my MCL as a as a firstyear scholar at West Ham. It was a painful experience because it was right before I was supposed to play in the FA Youth Cup games, which is like the pinnacle of the experience of being a scholar. FA Youth Cup is one of the biggest tournaments for scholars. So it was a frustrating experience. But yeah, tearing your MCL. so I had a grade two tear, so it was almost like fully, the ligaments were almost fully torn.
是的，出现过。我记得我的第一次大伤是我在西汉姆联队做第一年学员时撕裂了内侧副韧带（MCL）。那是一次痛苦的经历，因为那正是在我应该参加足总青年杯比赛之前，这对学员来说是巅峰体验。足总青年杯是学员最重要的锦标赛之一。所以那是一次令人沮丧的经历。但是是的，撕裂了内侧副韧带。我当时是二级撕裂，所以韧带几乎完全断裂了。
Luckily, I was able to manage it without getting a surgery, so I had to just wear a knee brace for almost 12 weeks, knee brace and crutches for almost 12 weeks and yeah how did that affect your mood at that time yeah very it was it was very difficult initially it was difficult to get your head around not playing and going through a new experience not knowing whether what's going to happen etc but one thing that really helped me was the fact that I was studying alongside alongside my football gave me something else to gave me something else to focus on yeah only my my a-level psychology alongside my football and I remember yeah so
幸运的是，我不需要手术就处理好了，所以我不得不戴了近12周的护膝，拄了近12周的拐杖。是的，那段时间这对你的情绪有什么影响？是的，非常困难。起初，很难接受不能踢球的事实，经历一种新的体验，不知道会发生什么等等。但有一件事真的帮到了我，那就是我在踢球的同时还在学习，这给了我其他可以专注的事情。是的，我在踢球的同时完成了我的A-level心理学课程，我记得是的，所以
after my day of rehab I go home and just um do some revision do some tests and it's um a good balance it's something I speak about my podcast in terms of having an identity on football something like that allows you to take your mind off it and put your teeth into something else where you can have some autonomy or um control over okay yes that locus of control stuff's really really important isn't it that's control control the things you can control rather than worrying about the things that you can't and i guess trying to nourish your body optimally so that you can repair the kind of tendon and ligament damage and so that you're maintaining your muscles elsewhere i think what i learned from my experience with my arm was your ligaments and your tendons get very wise very quickly when
在我一天的康复训练后，我回家复习一下，做些测试，这是一种很好的平衡。我在我的播客中谈到过，在足球之外拥有一个身份，这让你能够把注意力从伤病上移开，投入到其他事情中，在那里你可以拥有一些自主权或控制权。好的，是的，那种控制点理论真的很重要，不是吗？控制你能控制的事情，而不是担心你无法控制的事情。我想尽量以最佳方式滋养你的身体，以便修复肌腱和韧带的损伤，并保持其他部位的肌肉。我想我从手臂受伤的经历中学到的是，当你的韧带和肌腱不被使用时，它们会很快变得脆弱，并且会萎缩。它们萎缩的速度远快于它们生长的速度，而让它们再次生长实际上是最痛苦的部分之一。
they're not being used and they shrink up um and it they shrink far quicker than they grow um and the growing of them again is actually some of the most painful painful bits yeah definitely definitely yeah it's a frustrating experience especially with ligaments and tendons because they don't heal as well as bones especially tendons i recently had an injury a mallet finger injury which my tendon or my ligaments and tendons in my finger, they've been torn. So my finger now will never be straight again because the tendon wasn't able to heal properly. And it doesn't take quite a long time to heal.
是的，绝对是。这是一种令人沮丧的经历，尤其是韧带和肌腱，因为它们不像骨头那样愈合得好，尤其是肌腱。我最近受了伤，手指锤状指，我的手指韧带和肌腱撕裂了。所以我的手指现在永远不会变直了，因为肌腱没能正常愈合。而且它需要很长时间才能愈合。
So football is shaping your body for the better and the worse. Like you're stuck with that now. Yeah, yeah. Do you wear some wicked goalie gloves if you got cold hands in winter is a real problem for goalies that's what i've been experiencing have they got have you got some super duper gloves that stop that happening uh no not really i actually i'm sponsored i'm sponsored by um links goalkeeping which are a great goalkeeping brand tell us about tell us about them and their gloves yeah I feel like they're modern modern style of gloves
所以足球正在塑造你的身体，有好的一面也有坏的一面。就像你现在被困在那个伤病里一样。是的，是的。如果你在冬天手冷，你会戴那种很酷的守门员手套吗？这对守门员来说是个大问题，这是我一直经历的。你有那种超级棒的手套来防止这种情况发生吗？呃，没有，其实我是由Links Goalkeeping赞助的，这是一个很棒的守门员品牌。跟我们说说他们和他们的手套吧。是的，我觉得它们是现代风格的手套，
they're mainly on instagram they have a lot of high profile goalkeepers across the country different countries but they create a lot of content on youtube and on tiktok and just really appealing to the next generation of goalkeepers which is why i really like working with them they make amazing goalkeepers they make goalkeeping fun in which it is brilliant i will check that out and uh yeah have a look whether they do little people sizes as well as big people sizes um i'll be able to help sort you up oh bless you you're kind um so yeah have you got any kind of advice for i guess aspiring psychologists who might want to pursue sports psychology or or any professional
它们主要在Instagram上活跃，在全国乃至不同国家有很多知名守门员使用。但他们在YouTube和TikTok上创作了很多内容，真正吸引了下一代守门员，这就是我为什么真的很喜欢与他们合作。他们制作了很棒的守门员装备，让守门变得很有趣，这太棒了。我会去看看的，看看他们是否有小号和大人号的尺寸。我能帮你解决这个问题。哦，谢谢你，你真好。那么，你对那些可能想从事运动心理学或任何专业心理学途径，并且也对足球感兴趣的准心理学家有什么建议吗？如何避免在过程中精疲力竭？因为这真的非常非常难，而且不知道这是否是一场艰难的跋涉，最终能否得到你希望得到的奖赏。
psychology route and who might also be interested in football for not burning out on the way because it's really really hard and it's not knowing whether it's going to be a tough slog that has the prize at the end that you hope is going to be there yeah i would say don't do it just quit i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking but um the temptation the temptation is there sometimes i'm sure yeah yeah definitely you have to wait your why your why has to be strong your eyes to be strong in terms of why why you want to do it why you want to get qualified why you want to go down that period if your why is not
是的，我会说别做了，放弃吧。我在开玩笑，我在开玩笑。但有时诱惑确实存在，我相信。是的，绝对是。你必须权衡你的“为什么”。你的“为什么”必须足够强大，关于你为什么想做这件事，为什么想获得资格，为什么想走这条路。如果你的“为什么”不够强大，
strong enough then it'll be it'll be a very difficult thing. So on those days when you want to quit, you've got to really connect to your why. That's how you push through. That's how you get to another day. Yeah, 100%, 100%. And as well as that, you've got to be disciplined. You certainly are. They don't give away first-class degrees, and nor do they give away places on football teams. so you've obviously got a whole lot of discipline and
那么这将是一件非常困难的事情。所以，在那些你想放弃的日子里，你必须真正连接到你的“为什么”。这就是你坚持下去的方式。这就是你度过难关的方式。是的，百分之百。除此之外，你还必须自律。你当然是这样。他们不会轻易授予一等学位，也不会轻易给足球队名额。所以你显然有很强的自律能力，
your family and your friends and the way that you apply yourself you know you are wise and you know it pays dividends and so credit to you where it's due thank you very much thank you very much but yeah just to add on to that in terms of um advice yeah it's just about having a a balanced balanced schedule so when i was um final year last year whilst playing football final year dissertation etc everything football games balancing all of those things navigating social lives and everything I feel like it's just having a good organized schedule discipline and time management creating opportunities to to do other things other than football or work or school or uni work or
你的家人和朋友，以及你投入自己的方式，你知道你是明智的，这会带来回报，所以功劳归于你。非常感谢，非常感谢。但是的，补充一点建议，关于拥有一个平衡的时间表。所以当我去年最后一年时，一边踢足球，一边处理毕业论文等等，平衡所有这些事情，处理社交生活和一切。我觉得这只是拥有一个良好的组织时间表、自律和时间管理，创造机会去做足球、工作、学校或大学作业以外的事情，或者
placements or other things it's just yeah that work life work life balance really really important stuff and sometimes that looks like just laying down and doing nothing you know and sometimes we're able to say no to people to prioritize actually doing nothing and that's okay too isn't it have you got aims to maybe go on to become a sport and exercise psychologist what's the ultimate goal do you think because there will come a time when you will your body will start to say no to football you know you are still lovely and young at the moment but believe me that won't last forever um have you got an ultimate professional goal yeah yeah so obviously I spoke about my experience of um I didn't even speak about my experience of um working with psychologists in the academy system and um my experience with psychology dealing with negative experiences as a goalkeeper so yeah so studying psychology alongside that yeah just um but the work I've done with
实习或其他事情。这确实是工作与生活的平衡，非常重要。有时这看起来只是躺着什么都不做，你知道，有时我们能够对别人说不，优先考虑什么都不做，那也没关系，不是吗？你有没有目标去成为一名运动与锻炼心理学家？你认为最终目标是什么？因为总有一天你的身体会开始对足球说不，你知道你现在还很年轻，但相信我，那不会永远持续下去。你有什么最终的职业目标吗？是的，显然我谈到了我在青训系统中与心理学家合作的经历，以及我作为守门员在处理负面经历时运用心理学的经验。所以是的，在踢球的同时学习心理学，只是我在西汉姆联队时与运动心理学家合作的经历，
sports psychologists whilst being at West Ham really helped my game go to the next level allowing me to cope and be the player I am today so um we spoke about me or it being difficult to cope with mistakes or conceding goals as a goalkeeper is something that was really frustrating for me where if I made a mistake or if I maybe conceded a goal it will affect the rest of the training session or the rest of my next action or performance because of that mental mental fog or dwelling on that previous mistake. But working with sports psychologists at those different teams allowed me to develop coping mechanisms to reframe those situations and actually perform better, perform better.
真的帮助我的比赛提升到了一个新的水平，让我能够应对并成为今天的球员。所以我们谈到了我作为守门员在处理错误或失球时感到困难，这对我来说真的很令人沮丧。如果我犯了一个错误或者失球，它会影响我剩余的训练课或我接下来的动作或表现，因为那种精神上的迷雾或对之前错误的纠结。但在不同的球队与运动心理学家合作，让我能够发展出应对机制来重新构建这些情况，并实际上表现得更好。
So using stuff like positive self-talk, breathing techniques in order to deal with those negative thoughts whilst training or even in the games allowed me to take my performance to the next level. So just having experiences like that
所以使用积极的自我对话、呼吸技巧来处理训练甚至比赛中的那些负面想法，让我能够将表现提升到一个新的水平。所以拥有这样的经历，
and obviously studying psychology alongside that, I want to have my eyes set on becoming a qualified sports psychologist and, you know,
显然在踢球的同时学习心理学，我的目标是成为一名合格的运动心理学家，你知道，
having my own practice and using my experiences and qualifications to help the next generation of footballers take their performance to the to the next level that's ultimately the goal but it's the the accreditation pathway is it is daunting it is yeah there's there was multiple stages multiple stages um but yeah i i wish you all the very best with your um professional footballing career and you know where that may may take you but also your
拥有自己的诊所，并利用我的经验和资格帮助下一代足球运动员将他们的表现提升到一个新的水平。这最终是我的目标，但认证途径确实令人望而生畏。是的，确实有多个阶段。但我祝愿你在职业足球生涯中一切顺利，无论它将带你去向何方，也祝愿你未来的心理学职业生涯顺利。
psychology career in future and if there's anything i can do to support any of that at any point just give me a shout no i will do thank you very much thank you for taking the time to speak with our audience i know you're super super busy um so yeah thank you thank you again for your time daniel no worries no worries thank you for having me on this has been it's been really good you're so welcome what an absolute pleasure to speak with daniel thank you again for him in spending his time with us and helping us to look at the similarities and the differences between a psychology career and one as a professional footballer. Daniel seems very wise, even beyond his years, and very thoughtful. He was just recovering from a really awful cold. Hope
如果我有任何可以支持你的地方，随时告诉我。不，我会的，非常感谢。感谢你抽出时间与我们的听众交谈，我知道你非常非常忙。所以再次感谢你的时间，丹尼尔。不用客气，不用客气，谢谢你邀请我，这真的很好。非常欢迎，与丹尼尔交谈真是太愉快了。再次感谢他抽出时间与我们在一起，帮助我们审视心理学职业与职业足球运动员职业之间的相似之处和不同之处。丹尼尔看起来非常睿智，甚至超出了他的年龄，而且非常体贴。他当时刚从一场非常严重的感冒中恢复过来。希望
that by the time you listen to this, Daniel, you are feeling fully recovered. Daniel Gennadu can be found on YouTube, which is where his podcast is, and the podcast Beyond Football is also available on Spotify and Apple Podcasts. You can also follow Daniel on Instagram, on LinkedIn and TikTok, where he is Daniel Gennardou. I would love to know what this has evoked for you. Perhaps you're listening because you yourself are an aspiring sport and exercise psychologist, or perhaps you're listening just because you have an interest in all the different facets of psychology, or just in the interest of people, which is one of my specialist interests as well. If you, like me, are passionate about psychologists having a protected title, please do go and sign the petition,
当你听到这个的时候，丹尼尔，你已经完全康复了。丹尼尔·根纳杜可以在YouTube上找到，那是他的播客所在地，播客《超越足球》也可以在Spotify和Apple Podcasts上收听。你也可以在Instagram、LinkedIn和TikTok上关注丹尼尔，他的名字是Daniel Gennardou。我很想知道这引起了你什么样的共鸣。也许你正在收听是因为你自己就是一名有抱负的运动与锻炼心理学家，或者也许你收听只是因为你对心理学的各个方面感兴趣，或者只是对人感兴趣，这也是我的专业兴趣之一。如果你像我一样，热衷于让心理学家拥有受保护的头衔，请务必去签署请愿书，
which you can find by going to my LinkedIn profile, Dr. Marianne Trent. And there is a post there that is pinned where you can read all about the petition. At the time of recording this episode, we are on 8,707 signatures. When we get to 10,000 signatures, we will get some sort of feedback from the government. And when we get to 100,000 signatures, which we are not going to stop until we do, this will be considered for a debate in Parliament. So if you, like me, are passionate about this, please do sign that petition and do come on over to my Instagram as well, Dr. Marianne Trent. Let me know on there and let me know on LinkedIn that you have signed and why. I hope you find these podcasts really interesting. If you do, please follow the show on Spotify and
你可以通过访问我的LinkedIn个人资料Dr. Marianne Trent找到它。那里有一个置顶的帖子，你可以阅读关于请愿书的所有信息。在录制这一集时，我们已经有8707个签名了。当我们达到10000个签名时，我们将从政府那里得到某种反馈。当我们达到100000个签名时，我们将不会停止，直到我们做到这一点，这将进入议会辩论。所以如果你像我一样对此充满热情，请务必签署那份请愿书，也请来到我的Instagram，Dr. Marianne Trent。在那里告诉我，并在LinkedIn上告诉我你已经签署了以及原因。我希望你觉得这些播客非常有趣。如果你觉得有趣，请在Spotify和
or Apple Podcasts. Please subscribe, like the content, do all those good things, share it, tell your friends if you are watching on youtube thank you so much for watching come over to the free facebook group the aspiring psychologist community dr marianne trent consider the membership the aspiring psychologist membership and the books as well as the aspiring psychologist collective and the clinical psychologist collective thank you for listening and for watching and for being part of my world. The next episode will be available to you from 6am on Monday for the audio version
或Apple Podcasts上关注这个节目。请订阅、点赞内容，做所有那些好事，分享它，告诉你的朋友。如果你正在YouTube上观看，非常感谢你的观看。来到免费的Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区”，Dr. Marianne Trent，考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”以及书籍，还有“有抱负的心理学家集体”和“临床心理学家集体”。感谢你的收听、观看以及成为我世界的一部分。下一集将于周一早上6点提供音频版本，
and is available from 10am on Saturdays for the YouTube version. Take care and be kind to yourselves. Thank you. my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologist collective book i found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease
YouTube版本将于周六上午10点提供。保重，善待自己。谢谢。我叫亚娜，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，
and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。